foreign
[Music]
of a function measures its rate of
change
imagine a quantity denoted by variable Y
which is continuously changing
but how it changes is controlled by
another quantity denoted by variable X
we can say that the variable y called
the dependent variable is a function of
the variable X called the independent
variable
the function f tells us how the value of
y changes with the value of x
the derivative of a function at a
particular value of x
tells us the rate of change of Y with
respect to X at that particular value of
x
that is how fast or slow the value of y
changes with respect to X
in our previous video we saw how to find
the derivative of a function
the whole process is summarized like
this
and it's called differentiation
this ratio here is called the average
rate of change between two values of X
which are X naught and X naught plus
Delta X
if Delta X is greater than 0 then X
naught plus Delta X will be somewhere
here on the x-axis
then this ratio is the slope of the
secant line between these two points
now as we find the average rate in the
interval closer and closer to X naught
we see that these secant lines approach
the tangent line at X naught
this would be true even if we take Delta
X to be less than zero then X naught
plus Delta X will be somewhere here on
the x-axis
and as we find the average rate in the
interval closer and closer to X naught
we see that these secant lines approach
the tangent line at X naught
so we say that in the limit Delta X
tends to zero the average rate of change
approaches the instantaneous rate of
change at X naught
that is nothing but the derivative of
the function at X naught
we denote it by putting Dash like this
on the notation for the function
note that the limit Delta X tends to
zero does not mean we put Delta x equal
to 0 in this ratio
this would result in the ratio being
equal to 0 divided by 0 which does not
make any sense
in this video we will understand what
this really means
along with it we will also explore
different theoretical aspects of the
derivative of a function
consider this simple example
Y is equal to square of x
let's say we want to find the derivative
of this function at a particular value
of x say X1
can you find this out
actually in one of our previous videos
we found the answer to this
we had found the instantaneous speed of
an object for such a relationship
between the distance traveled and the
time elapsed
to find the derivative we would first
find the average rate of change
that is how the value of function
changes as the value of x changes by
Delta X
F of X1 plus Delta X and F of X1 will be
equal to this
after expanding this term and
simplifying we will get this
and after dividing by Delta X we will
get this final expression
now we know that to get the derivative
we will need to consider the interval
Delta X tending to zero
so we put Delta x equal to 0 here and
get this
it's the derivative of the function at
X1
but now notice that all these
expressions are equivalent to each other
so what if instead of putting Delta x
equal to 0 here we put Delta x equal to
0 here or here
we see that we will get the numerator
and the denominator both equal to zero
but for this final expression we got the
answer as 2 times X1
so what's going on here
why can't we substitute Delta x equal to
0 here and not here
actually substituting Delta x equal to 0
at any step here is not correct
notice that in these steps we are
dividing by Delta X
and we know we can't divide by zero
what Delta X tends to zero means is that
we are considering smaller and smaller
values of Delta X
the values of Delta X are close to zero
but never zero
but among all these steps here Delta X
does not explicitly occur in the
denominator here
so it's easy to see from this step that
as Delta X gets smaller and smaller the
average rate gets closer and closer to 2
times X1
so substituting Delta x equal to 0 here
is just convenient to reach this
conclusion
but always be aware of what it really
means to put Delta x equal to 0 here
now notice one more thing
although we had not explicitly stated
here here we took Delta X to be greater
than 0. that is we are finding the
average rate between X1 and the values
of X greater than it
but it is necessary to consider the case
when Delta X is less than zero
that is finding the average rate between
X1 and the values of X lesser than it
as we find the average rate when Delta X
tends to zero this average rate should
approach 2 times X1
so let's find the average rate in this
case when Delta X is less than zero
we can see the calculation for finding
the average rate of change will be the
same as this
but in the first case this average rate
will always be greater than 2 times X1
and in the second case this average rate
will always be less than 2 times X1
now when Delta X tends to 0 both these
average rates will approach the same
limit 2 times X1
now we can conclude that the derivative
of this function at X1 is equal to 2
times X1
so we see that to find the derivative of
a function at a particular value of x
we have to find the average rate of two
cases
when Delta X is greater than 0 and when
Delta X is less than zero
now when Delta X tends to 0 if both
these average rates approach the same
number then that number is the
derivative of the function at that
particular value of x
but consider this function now
it's called the absolute value or
modulus function
these vertical bars say that the value
of y is equal to only the non-negative
value of x
that is if x is greater than or equal to
0 then Y is equal to X
and if x is less than 0 then Y is equal
to negative of x
can you find the derivative of this
function at x equal to 0
share your thoughts in the comment
section below
we will find its derivative in the next
lesson
don't forget to subscribe in order to
get notified
[Music]
foreign